PROUD TO BE AN 8 NEWS NOW
COMMUNITY PRIDE PART.
>> WELCOME BACK TO LAS VEGAS.
NOW WE LIKE TO SAY THAT
DIAMONDS ARE EVERYONE'S BEST
FRIEND RIGHT WELL ON SEPTEMBER
8TH, IT'S S
TIME TO BREAK OUT
THE SPARKLES AND GET READY FOR
DRESS FOR SUCCESS OF SOUTHERN
NEVADA'S 10TH ANNUAL DIAMOND A
GUN HERE . TO TELL US ALL ABOUT
IT. WE HAVE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR NORMAN GO ALONGSIDE
ARLENE MILLER, THE OWNER OF MJ
CHRISTENSEN DIAMOND, THE MAIN
PARTNER FOR THE
EVENT LADIES
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, I'M
VERY EXCITED. I JUST JOINED
THE BOARD FOR JUST FOR
SUCCESS, THIS IS MY FIRST
DIAMOND START WITH YOU TELL US
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT DIAMOND A
GUN WHAT THAT MEANS IT SOUNDS
LIKE SO MUCH WITH THE FABIUS
EVEN I'M SO HAPPY TO SHARE
WITH THE AUDIENCE. THIS YEAR'S D
DIAMOND A
ARIS TAKING PLACE AT
THE GOOSE ISLAND LOUNGE THE
T-MOBILE ARENA IT'S GOING TO
BE FABULOUS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DIG
TABLES. WE'RE GOING TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE FABULOUS
PRICES THEY'RE GOING TO BE SO
MANY FUN ACTIVATIONS I
TREASURE CHEST A BUBBLE BARRED O
GRAB  AN THAT MAKES YOU SAKE
AMAZING FOOD, A SIGNATURE
DIAMOND COCKTAIL AND ALL FOR
AN AMAZING CAUSE TO HELP
EMPOWER WOMEN TO BE
ECONOMICALLY INDEPENDENT SO
THAT WOMAN HAVE THAT ECONOMIC
STATUS THAT WE NEED HERE
ACROSS THE VEGAS VALLEY AND
YOU GUYS ARE GOING BIG FOR THE T
10 YEAR C AND YOU ACTUALLY DO
DIG FOR DIAMONDS TELL US ABOUT
DOTHAT WORKS WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DIG TABLES IN IT WE'RE M
GOING TO HAVE ENTUS WAS A
FABULOUS GRAND PRIZE. WE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT MAY SEEM GRAND I
DO WELL THEY'VE RAGSTEPPED EUP
THIS YEAR AND SO WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE SHE SAID SANDBOX SO
WE'LL HAVE ABOUT 30 GEMSTONES
THAT NATURAL GEMSTONES LIFE
CAN BE DISCOVERED IN SAND.
>> THEY'LL ALSO HAVE OTHER
ITEMS TO DO THAT FOR PRICES
THAT CAN BE WON. BUT THE GRAND
PRIZE
TO EVATEDBECAUSE WE HAVE 2 SAND
IS YES IS A BEAUTIFUL CIRCLE
HALO PENDANT AND SO EACH
WINNER OF EACH SANDBOX GETS
ONE OF THOSE THAT SOUNDS
AMAZING AND YOU HAVE BEEN PART
OF THIS SINCE THE VERY
BEGINNING HOW DOES IT FEEL TO
BE A PARTNER AND TO HAVE SEEN
IT GROW OVER THE YEARS WELL,
YOU KNOW WHEN WE STARTED ABOUT
10 OR 11 I GUESS WE HAD TO
SKIP IT WAS IN OUR STORE, YOU
KNOW AND IT WAS FABULOUS WE
HAD A GREAT TIME IN AND WE
JUST OUTGREW IT, YEAH YOU KNOW
IT'S WEEK IT'S A GREAT THING
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE SO HAPPY
THAT THAT HAS GOTTEN TO THE
POINT THE T-MOBILE YOU KNOW
IT'S PRETTY COOL THEN YOU KNOW
SEPTEMBER 8TH AT T-MOBILE AND
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER FUN
THINGS PLANNED WE HAVE MYSTIC
MONA COMING NGOUT THERE SO MANY
THINGS THAT REALLY QUICKLY
NORMAL WHERE CAN PEOPLE GET
TICKETS IF THEY WANT TO GO
STRAIGHT TO OUR WEBSITE WWW.
>> D F S SOUTHERN NEVADA DOT
ORG AND GET YOUR TICKETS FROM
$50 $225 PACKAGE AND YOU CAN
WHEN TO PARTICIPATE IN ALL
THESE EVENTS THE TICKETS
INCLUDE THE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DAY AMAZING
I'M SO EXCITED SO HONORED T